I'm here with Deborah Amos author of
eclipses of the Sinise power exile and
upheaval in the Middle East Deborah you
argue that Iraq is now a virtual country
with so many of its people outside of
its borders what does that mean exactly
how does the Iraq function as this
virtual country in the refugee
communities in Damascus Amman Beirut
Iraqis recreate a little bit of home
it's most interesting with this
population because the internet only
came to Iraq in 2000
and then you had to go to a local
library or some institution you had to
sign up it was all you knows it was
really quite watched in 2003 Iraqi
bloggers took off and in in a way they
were ahead of other bloggers throughout
the region in 2003 so so they took to
this especially young Iraqis took to
this new technology which was newer to
them than anybody else in the region as
refugee populations these are middle
class educated people and so they have
their cell phones they sit in internet
cafes they're in chat rooms with each
other and unlike any other refugee
population I know they are able to keep
in touch daily they watch Iraqi
television which you know you can do
because of the satellite channels and in
a way they break themselves off from the
country they're living in and and
recreate this Baghdad and so they're
quite aware of details of politics
everything that's happening on the
streets violence that sometimes you and
I don't hear about but they know because
they're in touch all the time everyday
and and very keenly aware of political
movements who's up who's down I've never
quite seen anything like it in a refugee
population your title is eclipse of the
Sunnis which is something that must make
Sunnis in Iraq and elsewhere angry how
did you come up with this title and also
is it a reference to Sunnis in Iraq is
it a reference to the larger place of
Sunnis in the Arab world today
you know the book started out being
call first leave everything you love and
it was a much gentler title and it comes
from a Dante poem and it's about the
experience of exile which is what I
wanted to write about but the more I
started to see that there was a
sectarian component to this exiled
population my editor and I agreed that
the eclipses of the Sunnis was a bitter
title for Americans that title really
doesn't mean much a play on words maybe
they see the the picture on the front
it's a disturbed man Middle Easterners
look at that title and it's it's
shocking it's like a slap in the face
and I was talking to a friend in Beirut
who'd said he'd heard about the book and
I said well I hope that it makes it to
the shelves of an english-language
bookstore in Beirut but I bet no one
will put it in the window
it is so provocative as a title now who
am I talking about as you know this is a
region where Sunni Muslims are the
majority in most countries in the Middle
East and Shiites have been an aggrieved
minority Iraq was a different kind of
place Iraq had an aggrieved majority
they were under the thumb of the Sunnis
for for a long time the invasion changed
the equation the American invasion
changed the equation in Iraq they became
the you know for the first time ever
Arab Shias became the ruling sect in
Iraq so I am at first talking about Iraq
it is a sectarian divide there but I
also argue in this book that because of
the American invasion that sunni-shia
divide which is more a power divide than
a religious one has seeped throughout
the social fabric in all of the
countries of the Middle East that there
is now a divide that people feel not
religious mostly political and it has
disturbed the region and the region
hasn't come to terms yet with what Iraq
has become what it will become
and what this American invasion means
what are some of the ways you've seen
this divide play out you write a lot
about the regional consequences or the
unintended
as you put it a removing Saddam
Hussein's regime obviously this eclipse
of the Sunnis was was one of the
unintended consequences what else have
you seen and documented you know on the
ground in Iraq it became apparent
somewhere around 2004 when we first
arrived we didn't ask anybody who came
to work for us what they were it's it's
very American not to ask but it was very
clear when we would take translators out
to different neighborhoods it we learned
that you couldn't take a Shiite into a
Sunni neighborhood or a Sunni into a
Shia neighborhood so there's all that
grassroots divide that you feel in Iraq
but still there today most of the
neighbourhoods have become unmixed
before 2003 Sunnis and Shias would live
in the same neighborhoods now that is
most that is less likely let's remember
it was the Jordanian king who spoke
early on about something that he called
the Shia Crescent and what he was
talking about is he is a man who rules a
predominantly Sunni country that's
Jordan and he was worried about the
rising power of Iran that what the
invasion had done was to take Saddam out
of the equation and that was Iran's
biggest enemy and the Jordanian King
said it out loud
other Arab leaders felt it acutely but
didn't say it out loud that this was a
moment that Iran had what had become a
more powerful force in the country so
that is the geopolitical sunni-shia
divide and where you see this played out
is certainly in Lebanon you see it
played out in Syria in Saudi Arabia and
Egypt in all the places where you have
Sunni Shia populations you know it is
played out in different ways but as I
said earlier this is a political divide
not a religious divide this is not
people who are fighting in the mosques
this is this is about how politics and
power are going to be realigned in the
region and nobody really has an answer
to that yet and these you mentioned some
of the surrounding countries you
Jordan and Lebanon and Syria and Saudi
Arabia one of the things you touch on
and in the cases of Jordan and Lebanon
you write about this in great detail is
the impact that Iraq has had on those
countries but also what some of those
countries and what some of those regimes
and at least are doing inside Iraq
especially Jordan and Saudi Arabia and
Iran do you see any possibility for
stable Iraq with the pressure that a lot
of these countries exert um it depends
on how strong Iraq comes out of this
election but there's here's a couple of
examples the Saudi Arabian King has
never actually met with the Iraqi Prime
Minister who is a Shiite Saudi Arabia is
a predominantly Sunni country it they
have not put an ambassador in other
other Arab countries have done so but
the Saudis have resisted putting an
ambassador into Iraq and it's unclear to
me what that relationship is going to be
when Saddam was in power the Saudis and
Iraq actually were quite close and
fought on the same side in the iran-iraq
war and so that relationship will will
evolve over time where you really see
the divide is in Lebanon very early on
there were Sunnis in Lebanon who joined
the jihadist insurgents whatever you
want to call them inside of Iraq and
they felt that it was their place to go
and fight and what they were fighting
for was Sunni hegemony in the region not
again not in the mosque but as a
political battle and there were many of
them who went to Iraq who were trained
in urban warfare and then came home and
as you know this actually created a
crisis in Lebanon there was a group
called Fattah el Aslam these were people
who had come back from Iraq who had gone
through Syria into northern Lebanon and
you know there was a clash in the
country over this I spoke to a Sunni
Imam whose job it was to bring these
young men who now were in jail
them back into a non-violent way to
express their their views but you know
the thing that he noted about all of the
people who are on the Terrorism wing in
a Lebanese prison is they were all
Sunnis and this bothered him greatly how
is it possible that it's only us that
are considered terrorists on our in our
own country and so those tensions are
there how this plays in Iraq these
things take time
Iraq is certainly not a stable country
today as I say about the election that
has just passed you have democracy in
Iraq but without Democrats it's
interesting when you recount the
experience in Lebanon and some of the
other places in the region has Iraq
become something of Afghanistan in the
1980s where there was this great jihad
against the Soviet occupation of
Afghanistan in the 1980s a lot of young
men young mostly Sunni Arab fighters
would get trained sure four years in
Afghanistan and then there would be this
effective blowback they would go back to
their home countries places like Egypt
places like Saudi Arabia do you did you
find that pattern in Iraq as this place
for jihad and then these young men would
return to these countries and the impact
in countries other than just Lebanon you
know it's a little bit different than
Afghanistan there has been one occasion
Fatah al-islam and this is a group of
men who came to northern Lebanon and I
think you can explain that in that it is
easy for them to get across those
borders to go from Iraq to Syria to
Lebanon it is not so easy this time with
Interpol remember how many American
soldiers were in Iraq and they were very
very diligent in you know taking names
doing iris scans they have an amazing
amount of data this time that did not
happen in Afghanistan so I think it's
going to be a little harder than it was
and the model is an interesting one to
watch whether these young men who've now
been trained in urban warfare will be
able to seep back into their countries
and cause the kind of trouble that they
were able to do after Afghanistan I
think the model is going to be a little
bit different simply because many many
states have seen it before they expect
it to come and they're watching very
hard about anybody who has been in
inside Iraq and then tries to come home
certainly the Saudis are watching that
very closely because they've had their
own troubles with the you know a Saudi
version of al Qaeda the franchise that
opens in Saudi Arabia so the last thing
that they want is any of these young men
to come back into Saudi Arabia so I
think that people are watching the
borders a whole lot closer than they did
after Afghanistan let's go back to the
refugees for a moment you write very
critically about Prime Minister Nouri
al-maliki's in his response to the
refugee crisis and I think you're well
within your right to do that it was at
one point you met you talked about how
he called the refugees cowards for
leaving in Iraq you also described how
he went to Syria and tried to pressure
Syrian officials to close the border in
2007 this basically stopped the last
place that Iraqis could go to at the
height of the sectarian war you also
describe this interesting contradiction
Maliki himself was an exile he lived in
exile in the 1980s in Syria and Iran but
he spent a lot of time in Syria and
here's someone who became prime minister
of Iraq and had that personal
experiences in exile he had the personal
experience as someone who lived under
the shadow of Saddam's regime and tried
to organize and agitate against him so
how does he reconcile that personally
this experience of Exile and his
response to all the exiles that partly
his policies created well I had to think
a lot about that because you're
absolutely right to point out what a
contradiction it is but I came to the
conclusion that because of what he did
in exile he was a member of the Dawa
party it was an underground Shia
movement to unseat Saddam
and what he had to do every week is he
had to go see Syrian intelligence
explain what he was doing tell them what
he was doing there was some humiliation
in the in what he had to go through when
he was in exile but primarily what he
did was organized opposition to Saddam
Hussein he raised money for it he was
the logistics man you know if you were
going to send somebody over the border
on a mission Maliki would know about it
and so I think from that experience
he believes that that's what all exiles
do and this is a man who you know he was
in politics inside Iraq almost from the
very beginning as he was in the shadows
but you know after 2003 he was certainly
inside the green zone and I've always
wondered if he really understood what
was happening outside the green zone if
he understood what was happening to
civilians
how much mayhem was on the street how
many normal families who weren't
involved in politics at all were just
run out of their houses you know they
would get one of those notes that says
leave or die with it wrapped in a bullet
and you know that so many of them saw
their relatives killed in front of their
eyes and that's why they left I'm not
sure if he understood that but I've
certainly talked to UN people who deal
with refugees Ryan Crocker who was the
former ambassador to Baghdad what he
said about the Prime Minister is Maliki
sees a path asunder every Bush that he
believes that all of those people who
left and went to Damascus and went to
Amman our former Baathists are Saddam
supporters and there was no way that any
of us could talk him out of that and and
UN people say that he calls them cowards
and traitors and he had no sympathy for
them whatsoever which is demonstrated by
the kind of policies that the government
carried out they pledged 25 million
dollars in the spring of o7 they didn't
give it for another 18 months and it was
only 25 million at that time oil prices
were much higher they certainly could
have afforded to help those people and
Iraqis notice that you know for them it
was a shame how can we be so rich and
our government does nothing for us and I
think it was Maliki himself who because
of his own experience believes that you
were up to no
good if you left the country and you
were only conspiring against the powers
that were in Baghdad um it's really it
doesn't make a lot of sense in some ways
because it's so many of those refugees
where she has her fellow Shiites yes
they work yes they well it is part of it
too that Maliki just couldn't accept
that things under his regime and things
after Saddam could actually get as bad
as things were under Saddam I mean he
would he would easily or readily accept
that people had to go into exile and the
time of Saddam because there their life
was threatened but he's just not
imagined that people's lives could be
threatened in that same way it's
possible and that goes to the my
alternative theory which is if you were
in the green zone and and we know this
about the Americans you know how much
they missed about what was happening on
the ground and it's very possible that
there was a Green Zone syndrome and it
didn't matter whether you are an
American or an Iraqi that you really
didn't understand what was happening
outside the walls you had protection you
had guards your family was safe you were
not living in a neighborhood you had
electricity you had water and so all of
that was so foreign to you about what
was going on and remember this he was
eight didn't come in as a strong leader
and when the biggest bulk of the exiles
were leaving which was in 2007 he was
under pressure from the bush
administration this was both of them had
a reason to say things were going well
this was at the time of the surge Iraq
was turning around that was certainly
his message mr. Maliki's message as
Prime Minister but you're absolutely
right it's not just Sunnis who left
there were plenty of Shias who left the
country who were under the same
pressures as Sunnis were lever died we
will kill you you must go there was such
chaos on the ground that there were
plenty of people leaving the country on
a related note you explained Maliki's
encounters with Syria on trying to
pressure Syria to close the border so
that you can stop this flow of refugees
what were some of the other ways that
you documented
of the refugees becoming pawns of this
larger regional battle going on and
pawns of Iraqi policy towards these
neighboring countries and also the
neighboring countries using the refugees
as pressure points on Maliki's
government well one of let me talk about
a little bit wider first with the
Americans I think by 2007 there was such
pressure in Washington to deal with the
refugees the late Senator Kennedy did a
lot of working in Congress and Maliki
felt that he had to show that he was
doing something and so in 2007 there was
a caravan that was put on 20 buses and
the government was offering $800 per
refugee they were all loaded on buses
this was supposed to go on for months
but it was you know the most shambolic
trip you can imagine it took 48 hours to
get there they had helicopters following
the buses they had police escorts they
took them to the wrong hotel their
relatives showed up in another hotel the
international press was there and there
were many in Washington who could
declare victory look they're all coming
back and Malachy was very happy with
that the problem is many of those people
who left were either kidnapped or killed
because they had 800 bucks in their
pocket and there was no other convoy
that year it was a disaster on the
ground
and almost every refugee understood that
and didn't get on those buses they tried
it again a second year disaster as well
people didn't come back how it plays
regionally I think both Syria and Jordan
use what they've done for Iraq as a
negotiating tool the Syrians tell me
that every time Maliki comes to Damascus
where they talk to him they always put
refugees on on the agenda and he always
takes it off he doesn't want to talk
about it the Jordanians say the same
thing they really want to talk about it
and and he doesn't want to I think more
the bigger problem between Iraq and the
neighbors is that this if this goes on
for I don't know a generation as refugee
crises tend to do in the region but then
it becomes a destabilize
in population you have so many children
of the families who have arrived who are
outside the education system these are
middle class people who are moving into
poverty their children aren't in school
I often see where the fifteen-year-old
can read and the seven-year-old can't
and the seven-year-old is probably not
going to learn how to read because that
family doesn't have those children in
school I mean think about what that
means 10 years from now 15 years from
now these are people who feel that they
have gotten a very bad deal and it's
very possible that this is a great
recruiting ground I don't say that you
know we don't know that and and I don't
want to criminalize refugee populations
but what we do know is in poor countries
refugee populations are destabilizing
that is what history shows about the
region and have you seen and documented
examples already of this destabilization
thinking especially in place like Jordan
where there's been sunni-shia attention
at one point there was a large influx of
Shia refugees to Jordan there were
issues where some of the Shiites would
try to start their own Hassan ia's which
is their their version of the mosques
and the Jordanians got very worried
about that as you pointed out the
Jordanian King was already worried about
this Shiite Crescent yeah so what were
some of the ways that we're already
seeing destabilizing influences and and
and the sectarian kind of growth in
these places let's look Jordan is a
really interesting case in 2005 Zarqawi
who was the the head of the local
al-qaida sends his people refugees into
Jordan and blows up three hotels
so Jordan decides that's destabilizing
enough thank you very much and they
closed the border - she is not soon as -
she is and I think at that moment Jordan
decided which side they were going to be
on on this sectarian divide in 1991
Jordan took plenty of Shias in another
moment when Iraq was hemorrhaging
refugees and
and made that a haven for Iraqis you
know eventually more than a million
people in 92 came through Jordan by 2003
there was about 300,000 of them left
quietly living in Jordan so it's not the
Jordan hadn't dealt with Hsieh refugees
they had but their door was firmly
closed and they would separate families
on the border if you were in a mixed
marriage and you got to the border and
and mom was a she and dad was a Sunni
dad could come and mom could not it was
incredibly hard on people the reason
that the Exile population is so large in
Syria is because they let everybody in
that was the border and you know I think
that Iraqis will remember this for a
long time about who let them in and who
didn't both Shia and Sunnis because they
all talk about it because she has had to
leave as well and they could go to Iran
but they couldn't go anyplace else they
could not go to Egypt they could not go
to Jordan they could get to Lebanon but
they had to go a very circuitous route
and they won't forget that so for she
added the two routes were Syria and Iran
for Sunnis it was a little better right
now Syria Jordan Egypt they could get on
a plane they could go to Turkey they
could get on a plane um but they were
not treated very well in any of those
places and they weren't allowed to work
they found themselves in the gray
economy it they are sliding into
destitution the international community
is tiring of supporting them not that
they ever really wanted to in the first
place certainly in Europe the idea was
this was America's problem and it should
be the Americans who do most of the
heavy lifting when it comes to money
the Americans have at put in money more
in Jordan than in Syria because it's
been difficult because of the
relationship between these two places
Washington the Damascus to put money
into Syria there has to be sort of
different routes to do that because
America cannot Washington because of
congressional sanctions cannot put money
directly into Damascus
and I I think even the UN worries about
how much longer the international
community will support this population
and there is no indication that they are
going home anytime soon on that note
both Jordan and Syria the two places
that have taken in the largest number of
refugees constantly talk about the
strain that the refugees have caused on
their social systems on schools on
health care and they've received some of
this international aid for a long time
they tried to pressure Washington to
provide more aid and the Iraqis have
provided a measly sum of 25 million how
much of a strain do they really pose on
these countries and and is there a way
to separate the political use of these
refugees from the actual sort of impact
that they have in these places it's very
difficult to make that separation and
they have all juiced up the numbers when
it suited them Jordan has made some very
strategic deals on how their schools
will be funded when they have Iraqi
refugees that what they've essentially
said is any program that you do for
Iraqis you must also do for Jordanians
and they have benefitted Syria has
opened a university that is run by Iraqi
professors some of the best in Baghdad
who were run out by militants and found
themselves in Damascus it's a it's the
Syria's first University that offers all
instruction in English with it's a
private university with a with a tuition
that is about seven thousand dollars
we're in the Gulf it might cost a parent
thirty-three thousand dollars to get
their child into an equivalent College
so they've gotten some benefits out of
these people but you also have to say
that both governments subsidize water
gasoline bread healthcare education and
so it has been a strain on both
governments so there's been the good and
the bad and they have both both Amman
and Damascus have learned how to play
the refugee game both countries have had
a history
of taking refugees they know how it
works
Palestinians are in great number in
Jordan Jordan probably has by percentage
more refugees than any other country in
the region Syria also has its its share
of Palestinian refugees so they know the
political game of how this works I'm not
saying that either country thought about
that when their borders were open when
they let people come I think both
countries have a commitment to Arab
Brotherhood and they did feel bad for
these people they needed someplace to go
and you have to give them credit for
allowing them to come and live in safety
what about the impact on the social
structure in Jordan and Syria you
describe rents going up in both places
you describe increasing the price of
food which in Syria is extremely serious
and the kind of small resentments that
begin to build up within Jordanian and
Syrian communities that begin to think
well maybe we're giving too much to
these refugees well think about this
you've just described all the bad things
that have happened so you would think
that at some moment both Jordanians and
Syrians would turn on these refugees
because they're easy to find they're in
big neighborhoods but the more important
thing is that they haven't yes there's
grumbling no doubt about that those
Iraqis are rough and they don't say
please er thank you and we thought that
they were more sophisticated than they
are you know there's a lot of grumbling
I had to move out of my neighborhood
because I just about had it with all
these Iraqis yes that that happens but
considering the impact on their own
societies it has always been impressive
to me that both Jordanians and Syrians
have accepted these Iraqis into their
myths now mind you they tend to you know
Christians go to Christian neighborhoods
Sunnis go to Sunni neighborhoods she
heads go to Shiite neighborhoods in and
certainly in Damascus not not in Jordan
and and so that smooths the way a bit
but they have been incredibly generous
incredibly gracious I mean look the
numbers for example are like 50 million
if this happened here by percentage in
our population 50 million people we're
talking about can imagine if 50 million
Canadians showed up in the United
and said please can you feed me and can
you put my kids in school you know it's
I don't know how Americans would react
so you have to give them some credit for
that thank you we're going to take a
short break and we'll be back soon with
Deborah Amos author of the clips of the
Sunnis afterwards and several other
c-span programs are available for
download is podcast more with Deborah
Amos and Mohammed bazi in a moment this
weekend on c-span 2's book TV Arundhati
Roy on the war on terror democracy in
India and india-pakistan relations her
book is field notes on democracy and New
York Post columnist and Fox News analyst
ralph peters looks at u.s. foreign
policy in his latest collection of
articles endless war on afterwards
NPR foreign correspondent deborah amos
on what's happened to the sunnis
following the fall of Saddam Hussein
find the entire weekend schedule at book
TV org and follow us on Twitter
afterwards with Deborah Amos and
Mohammed Bazzi continues Deborah in this
book you chronicled many heartbreaking
stories of refugees who are lost
everything Iraqis who had been forced
out of their homes because we're I think
cleansing and Baghdad and elsewhere
people who had lost relatives loved ones
people who have been kidnapped and only
made it out alive by miracles and these
stories really permeate all through the
book it must have been very difficult to
gather these stories were there some of
these stories that stood out most for
you as heartbreaking as every story was
what were the stories that stood out
most I think and which is why I use it
as a chapter head because it there are
two things I wanted to write about I
wanted to write about the Christian
community and they were the first to
leave the country but I also met a young
man
who had lived in the neighborhood of
Dura there was so much writing early on
about beheadings and I know that my
colleagues male colleagues who went to
Iraq were terrified they'd have
nightmares about this idea of beheadings
and that you would find yourself in an
orange jumpsuit and there would be a guy
with a big sword and he would cut your
head off that was really really
troubling and so I met this young
Christian Christian man who had been
kidnapped by a local al Qaeda group
that's who they said they were they were
followers of Abu Musab al-zarqawi
and they just decided that it was their
job to try people for what they
considered traitorous crimes working for
the Americans working for what they saw
as the apostate Iraqi government and
this poor young man was kidnapped
because that he'd been trying to apply
for college so he was leaving the house
every morning at 7 a.m. and for them
that meant if he was being that regular
about something he was probably working
for the government or the Americans and
they bundled him in a car and took him
to this underground prison which really
was a house where they would lock the
doors and and called his home and told
his mother and father if we find out
after an investigation that this young
man was working for the Americans
we shall behead him and his father very
quickly said if you find out he's been
working for the Americans I'll cut his
head off and that I think in some ways
may have saved his life but he was
forced to watch three trials and three
executions three beheadings and it's
hard for me to even imagine what that's
like to have that film in your head
by the time I met him in Damascus he was
very quiet very introspective very odd
I'm sure that he had some sort of
post-traumatic stress reaction to that
because part of what he had to watch was
an 11 year old boy who had also been
picked up off the street a kid who when
they said to him at his core
trial did you tell the Americans that
there were bombs on the street he
eventually said yes but I promise never
to do it again but that wasn't enough
and so he was also beheaded now the good
news is that this young man the bras has
been resettled he's in California and he
called me when he got to California just
to say you know hurray I made it I was
in Baghdad when I got that call and I
wish him well there in California I hope
that he feels safe in California and I
used his story because it is horrific
but there were so many people who had
terrible things happen to them I was
standing in one day in Douma which is
where the Iraqis come to register in
Damascus and they had a mobile clinic
because a lot of times these Iraqis
would have no medical attention until
they signed up with UNHCR and and there
was a woman who had been taken off the
line because she'd been gang-raped by 27
men and you know she really needed some
serious medical attention I think so
many of these refugees have seen the
very darkest of human behavior and these
are the kind of people who probably
won't go back
if you Rock turn into Disney World they
won't go back I think it's too traumatic
for them many of them never leave their
rooms many of them are now incredibly
damaged and really needs some sort of
trauma counseling but because there's so
many of them it's not available
and you write very vividly and movingly
about the experience of iraqi women who
have been forced into prostitution
especially in syria just tell us how
that has happened and and how you were
able to gain access to these women and
document what they go through um I'm not
shocked by prostitution
it happens in wars it happens it is a
economic choice for some people what was
so disturbing in Syria and the reason
that I really spent a lot of time trying
to gain access to
the community was these were
middle-class women many of them educated
from a conservative society to make this
kind of choice to decide to engage in
what's called survival sex for many of
them would mean that they would never be
able to go home
that if their families knew what they
had done to survive in Damascus it would
shame the family so badly that their
lives would be at risk and even so even
knowing that they still did it of course
I was disturbed by the families the
mothers and fathers who would sell their
twelve-year-old daughters that was
equally disturbing but I I wanted to
document the women who I felt I have a
lot in common with and so I was lucky
enough to meet a translator who I'd
known in Baghdad who happened to be in
Damascus the same time I was and I said
can you help me can you introduce me to
someone and and I can probably take it
from there but I need your help just to
make that first introduction and she
took me to an apartment where I met a
woman named Eleanor she was in her 30s
she had two kids she'd come from a mixed
marriage she'd lived in Deraa her
husband was a Shiite she was a Sunni and
the reason that she had been forced to
flee is there was she had acid thrown on
her which was you know the biggest sign
ever that that was the first step and
she was going to have to leave her
husband left her and her children she
was on her own and she was the one who
brought me into this world and what I
really wanted I had gone to some of the
clubs on my own but only with
translators and we visited a couple it
was very uncomfortable to do it that way
what
well Noor was able to do is to bring me
with her as part of the crowd it was
uncomfortable I knew what I was in for
we met at midnight I kind of didn't
quite have the clothing for what this
was going to require but it was dark I
knew it was going to be dark and she
said that you know what I didn't have in
cleavage I could make up with mascara so
it was an Iraqi application of makeup
I spent time in the ladies room with all
of these women who spent their time
showing each other their pictures of the
children on their cell phones it was
like you know being at the office until
everybody walked out and walked up on
the stage and some I asked to come to
lunch I told them at that point that I
was a journalist I think one of them
knew she was my partner and we danced
together on stage and I think she knew I
was a journalist because she was one and
that was very telling that here are the
two of us two women in the same
profession from two different countries
and forced one of us is forced to take
extreme measures and it's about her kids
what's been the Syrian government's
response to the book no to the
prostitution issue in particular well to
be to be fair to them when they see
girls 13 14 15 being abused by their
families and there has been there have
been raids on apartments where you know
10 13 year-olds are taken into custody
they are put into some protective it's
it's a jail but it is protective and
because these girls are in these places
their parents can't get to them here's
here's the problem when the UN sits down
with the family and they do have case
workers who are out trying to to stop
this and they say look we can give you
$200 a month if you'll take your
daughter out of the trade and what the
family says is $200 a month
I can make $200 a night with my daughter
and that has been a problem the Syrian
Red Crescent has opened some centers for
trauma counseling but it's a problem
that nobody can quite get their hands on
you know part of the prostitution trade
is of course fronted by Syrians there
was a time when it was Russian women who
were in this business Moroccan women who
were in this business but the Iraqi
women have actually moved those girls
out because they're cheaper and so in a
way Syria private business does benefit
from these women and you know what
country actually makes such a crackdown
on prostitution it happens all over the
world let's go back up to some of the
regional consequences of this crisis you
described in the book may of 2008 in
Lebanon where Hezbollah the Shia militia
and in Lebanon basically took over West
Beirut the the largely Sunni part of
Beirut and this was something that was
witnessed and it was something that was
documented and everyone sort of in the
entire Middle East was on edge
seeing the Shiite force exert its power
within Lebanon in this way
how much did Iraq have to do with that
everything well that probably isn't
completely fair because it would assume
that the Lebanese don't have their own
national interests but so much of it did
have to do with Iraq as as I've said in
the earlier parts of this interview
there were plenty of young men in in
northern Lebanon and in eastern Lebanon
who decided that they were going to go
fight in Iraq and and what they saw is
they were fighting against the Americans
but they were also fighting against an
american-backed Shia Arab government
something that that was a historic
change in the Middle East now as we know
Hezbollah is an ally of Iran and if you
look at the geopolitical importance of
Iraq this is where we have uncomfortable
competition between the Americans and
the Iranians so what we were seeing in
Lebanon in 2008 was essentially the same
conflict carried out by different actors
yes they have their own interest on the
ground but it is also part of this
regional competition for who actually
has the most influence in the region and
I think that what was interesting about
the outcome in 2008
set the stage for what has happened ever
since the truth of the matter is that
Hezbollah Iran and Syria won that round
whether the Americans were willing to
acknowledge it or not that is what
happened and everybody in the region
understood that Hezbollah Iran and Syria
had won that particular round and I
think that that's informed politics ever
since in fact it is being the region a
little bit more stable because there was
a recognition that these guys won this
round is there this new force in the
region where Shiites are the standard
bearer of Arabism oh if we look at his
bowl on Lebanon if we look at looked at
a Sutter in in Iraq both forces that
have fought me and Hezbollah's case it's
fighting the Israelis and then looked at
a service case that's fighting the
Americans very purely Shiite forces both
allied with Iran are they becoming this
new standard bearer of Arab nationalism
well that's an interesting question and
that maybe in some ways they are there
is another force now I think that we
have to put into the mix and that's the
Turks they've become much more active in
the region it has in some Arab capitals
they're seen as the Sunni balancer
because turkey is a predominantly Sunni
country although I think that the Turks
would be very uncomfortable with that
mantle they're the Ottoman Empire and
they remember what it was like when they
had influence in the region and and that
may be a new part of the balance in the
Middle East you know I think that the
way that Washington looks at the region
it's the moderates versus the radicals I
think in the region people don't look at
it that way it's much more fluid how
these things work and much more fluid
how these alliances work in some ways
Iraq has skewed the way Washington
analyzes who's up and who's down in the
region I I find that it looks much
different on the ground about who's up
and who's down and and where where
interests lies so I suppose you can
argue and it's an interesting argument
that the the two big Shia forces in the
region the most successful ones so far
are the standard bearers of some sort of
Arab nationalism you know the
cross-border never mind the borders and
I look these are all historical forces
these are things that have to happen the
Shia populations by sheer numbers must
be taken into account in the same way
that I argue that this newly empowered
Shia government and Iraq has to have
some power sharing with Sunnis because
they don't live in an island the truth
of the matter is that I think that it
would be a wise move for a Shiite
dominated government in Iraq to ask the
Saudis well exactly how are you treating
your Shiites if you care so much about
how we're treating our Sunnis and ask
Bahrain where the majority population
there are Shiites exactly how are you
treating your Shiites I mean those are
questions that have to be answered in
this region and they're so acutely on
the table that it would be a stabilizing
move to do that whether that happens or
not I'm not sure you raise a very good
point is there other places in the
region where we might see similar
spillover from Iraq as we saw in Lebanon
you raised Saudi and you raised Bahrain
obviously both places don't have the
kind of force that Hezbollah possesses
and Lebanon there's no armed militia
there's no almost a private it's a
private army basically in Lebanon but
are there places where we might see the
spillover that that you write about it
is possible in Bahrain in fact I have
read that Bahrain is not only accepting
Iraqi refugees Sunnis in particular but
giving some of them citizenship to
change the demographic balance in the
country
is an aggrieved Shia majority in the
same way that we used to see it in Iraq
they can see what's happening in Baghdad
they can take some comfort in a rise of
a new Shia power in the region it's
possible that you will see a spill out
probably more there than anyplace else
there's not that kind of cleavage that
it would matter in Egypt or Jordan or
even Syria for that matter
so if Bahrain maybe maybe the place
where you see some actual spillover do
you think we're still going to see
Sunnis radicalized all over the region
because of Iraq I certainly hope not and
I think that the outcome of this
election in Iraq will go some way to
tell us where we're headed in the next
decade for the first time ever you do
have a Sunni political bloc ironically
led by a she had the odd allowi is a
Shiite what's called a secular Shiite
which is an odd thing but he looks like
he has rallied most of the Sunnis behind
him it's been interesting to watch in
this election that the Islamist Sunni
parties did very badly and the awakening
the Sunni group that aligned themselves
with the United States against Al Qaeda
I would have thought they would have
done better in this election but I think
Iraqis have decided that people who are
aligned with the United States they
weren't gonna vote for and they didn't
the danger is that Fiat allows party one
from a lot of votes Baghdad north in in
the Sunni part of the country the Shiite
parties won Baghdad and south but if
allowi won enough votes that he cannot
be ignored the question is how will he
be integrated how will his party be
integrated how where will where will she
Sunnis end up in what cabinet positions
will they have where will they be in the
military and I think that will tell us a
lot
about what happens to the refugees how
easy it is to radicalize people by
saying you've been left out you've been
cheated you've been tricked you all went
to the polls and where did it get you
nowhere you know if if we end this
election in Iraq with people being able
to say that then that's a very dangerous
time I think in the region already you
are seeing top generals in the United
States
talk about Middle East politics is is
intrinsically interest of interest to
American troops on the ground
the latest report is about Israel
Palestine if we don't have a good
outcome in this election one can imagine
that same sort of report done by top
generals saying you know Iraq is is bad
for American interests the Exiles the
refugees in the surrounding countries
were able to vote in the recent
parliamentary election but they didn't
vote in as large of numbers as anyone
had expected and I think you might have
been a little surprised by by the
numbers does that indicate that there
are fewer refugees than we had thought
does it indicate that they've given up
on the political process back home one
of the arguments you make is that this
is a different refugee population than
then almost anything we've seen before
where they're connected to home so
strongly in the way that they they have
to go back and forth in some ways from
Syria to keep residency they're also
connected to home just by the fact that
they have so many relatives who are
still there so why didn't they vote in
the numbers that we might have expected
them to yeah the numbers that the Iraqi
High Commission for elections expected
was between 160 and 180 thousand in
Syria alone and there were politicians
who Sunni politicians who went to Syria
and actually campaigned there I wrote to
a friend of mine who works for the
International Crisis Group and said what
do you make of the numbers and he said
look most of us never believe the
official numbers of how many exiles were
in the in Damascus that doesn't mean
it's not a crisis
a hundred thousand is a crisis outside
the country so 42,000 voted in Syria I
think we still don't know what it means
about the ultimate number of exiles but
what what he says and and you know I
have been there and I wasn't there for
the run-up to the elections what he says
is that so many of them feel that
they've been abandoned by their
government even by the politicians who
came up to campaign that they'd never
seen them before you know all of a
sudden before Election Day they arrive
and they want people to come out and do
something they want support but the
question for these refugees and what
have you done for us nothing nothing at
all and you're part of this government
structure you're part of this permanent
political class that rules Baghdad and I
suppose that what we should say instead
is 42,000 came out to vote these are
people who aren't living a great life in
exile and so you still have 42,000
people who are invested in the country I
go back to a number there are 230
thousand refugees who are registered
with UNH see we've got and it doesn't
represent everybody there those are the
people who are interested in being
resettled the rest of them whatever
their numbers are want to go home so the
fact that we had 42,000 vote tells you
that at least in in March of 2010 that
there were that many people who are
still invested in Iraq now if this
government that is about to form if this
government does not find a way to either
support them or bring them back then my
guess is there won't be a single one who
votes next time and these refugees are
going to watch very closely the
formation of the next government yes
that's something that could take four or
five six months as all the different
factions finally when they finally get
their allotment of seats no one is going
to have a clear majority there's going
to be a lot of backroom dealing over the
Prime Minister spot and also over the
presidency so what will the refugees be
watching for in that backroom dealing
and is there any way that they can get
they didn't vote in large numbers so is
there any way that they can get some of
their issues on the table maybe more aid
to some of the surrounding countries you
know mr. Lau II who is now the head of
strangely the head of this Sunni bloc
has spoken about helping exiles he's
he's an Hashim II who was a president
and will and and and aligned himself
with allow he also has been a proponent
of doing something about the exiles so
let's see what they do when they come
into government if they do here's what I
think that the refugees are going to be
watching for where the cabinet posts who
gets them and the reason I say that is
in an economy where the government is
the major employer you need to have a
government job to have a future in Iraq
there's just not enough of a private
economy and to have a government job
it's pretty much done on a sectarian
basis this is not a system that works on
merit the best candidate doesn't always
win if let's say a occurred becomes the
head of the foreign ministry you can
pretty much bet that most of the people
who have those jobs in that ministry are
all Kurds and I think what Sunnis need
to see is where do we fit how can we get
jobs how do we support our families and
so on a very basic level they want to
know that the second thing they want to
know is who's going to fix all these
houses that are in dispute how are we
going to get our houses back is anybody
going to talk about that is that going
to be discussed in Parliament is the
army going to work harder at that is
there going to be money that we actually
get if we come back you know the
government had offered $800 but they ran
out of money last year and nobody got it
and there were NGOs who were documenting
how much people got and only 10% of the
returnees got that money which meant the
returnees stopped coming back because
you need a little pot of money to get
started again so these they do have
specific issues and both a and the
internally displaced are kind of
watching for these specific kinds of
policies before they really make a
decision because for many of them that
once you go back you can't really get
out again and what what are we going to
see as this political jockeying unfold
we've talked about how the refugees are
going to see it and what they're going
to look for what will the surrounding
countries look for and what kind of
alliances can we expect one of the
things we saw right before this election
was yeah de la we being invited to Saudi
Arabia she was and trying to strengthen
his his relationships with some of the
Arab powers so what will some of those
neighbors Jordan Syria Saudi Arabia Iran
what will they be looking for well
they're all be looking for something
different and they all put a ton of
money into the campaigns because they
all had their candidates you know this
is a region where everybody watches
everybody else and if you're weak you
can expect that your neighbors are going
to dabble which is what happened I think
they are the neighbors are going to be
watching for a coalition that emerges
that makes the country more stable and
that will tell them where Iraq is headed
if there is some power sharing in the
region what it means to ear ox Sunni
neighbors is that Iraq is going to go it
alone they won't be an Iranian proxy and
that will be important to Saudi Arabia
to Egypt to Jordan and even to Turkey in
some ways I think what the Iranians are
going to watch for is that the bath is
what they consider the Sunnis aren't too
strong